when a runtime of less than two hours
was announced for Justice League some
fans were shocked suspecting that the
team up movie had been drastically cut
down during reshoots and the final edit
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm breaking down and
explaining everything deleted and
changed in the final curse of Justice
League including some great lines and
scenes teased in the trailers plus some
cameos we never got to see I'm also
currently running a giveaway for two
Justice League the art of the film
hardback books which are full of
gorgeous concept art and
behind-the-scenes shots from the set to
enter make sure you're a subscriber and
let me know what you think about any of
the deleted scenes or reshoots quick
spoiler warning I will be discussing
changes to the movie so be aware of that
if you haven't seen it yet one reported
objective of the movie's reshoots was to
lighten the tone of the film
for example actor Joe Morton who plays
Victor Stone's father Silas said he
believes the studio requested
adjustments to cyborg to make him less
serious there's evidence of a lot of
deleted scenes with cyborg from the
early trailers some of them indicate we
were going to learn more about his
previous football career and there's
another cutscene with cyborg which
included a cameo by marc McClure the
actor who played Jimmy Olsen in the
Christopher Reeve era Superman movies in
the deleted Justice League clip McClure
plays a policeman whose cyborg saves
from a burning wreckage
you should probably move from Ray Fisher
has also revealed there was a scene of
Victor and his mother presumably a
flashback which Fisher is described as
really special and unique and there's
another cutscene in the trailers where
cyborg tells Batman he thought he wasn't
real
didn't think you were real I realize
useful in early 2016 it was also
reported that willem dafoe was cast as
volcko for justice league however his
character was completely cut from the
movie according to Jason Momoa in an
earlier version of the film
Aquaman spent more time underwater than
we see in the final movie and we would
have seemed a foes character volcko as
Aquaman's connection to Atlantis and the
person who gave Aquaman the idea that
he's the rightful king Zack Snyder's
vision for the film was to establish
Aquaman's anger at feeling like an
outcast who's not at home either at sea
or on land Koyuk book movie fans of
course will know Willem Dafoe is the
Green Goblin from Sam Raimi spider-man
films however his character volcko will
be appearing in next year's Aquaman
movie the first Justice League trailer
reveals deleted scenes of some rather
Snyder esque shots of Bruce Wayne
trekking with his horse through the icy
wilderness before he reached Aquaman's
fishing village
yeah
we have to be ready
you'll be the others I suspect this sort
of visual storytelling was a casualty of
the editing process and the reported
directive from the Warner Brothers CEO
that the final movie should be no longer
than two hours a number of comedic
moments were also victims of this pretty
strict requirement with Diana and
Bruce's more more or more less quit
getting the chop from the final film
he said he'll fight with us
more and more or less probably more or
less he said no he said no another
priests wine scene that ended up on the
proverbial cutting room floor showed him
looking at what seems to be a hologram
of Supergirl I wonder if the idea was to
have her in contact with Batman after
her cousin died there's also some
deleted dialogue in one of the trailers
where Bruce talks about having a dream I
had a dream it was the end of the world
and I'm guessing this was a reference to
Batman's nightmare in BVS Batman himself
also had a short line cooked when he
says my turn after getting into the
Nightcrawler watch her
Ezra Miller's Barry Allen had a stack of
deleted scenes - first is an intriguing
and very cool shot of Barry breaking
through a pane of glass with the tip of
his finger
[Music]
the cutscene has an interesting visual
parallel to how flash appeared to Bruce
Wayne at the end of the nightmare
sequence in BBS and more importantly to
a moment in Justice League where very
gently pushes Wonder Woman sword back
towards her showing how far he's come
since he broke that glass notice also
that there's a woman behind Barry in
this cut moment and I wonder whether
this could be a flashback to when either
Barry got his powers or how he learns
about what he can do there's a cool shot
of the flash taking out a para diamond
during the tunnel sequence and this
looks like it was cut too short in the
action scene Ezra Miller and Jason Momoa
have also revealed there was a comical
scene cut where Barry and Aquaman are in
a van and they're trying to figure out
what superhero name to give him as he's
not called the flash yet in the deleted
scene Barry is going on and on about it
and makes a few suggestions such as
lightning boy or lightning lad
Aquaman then quips back how about
motormouth which makes Barry spit out
his food and then he replies well what
about comedy man the names lightning boy
and lightning lad are actually comic
book Easter eggs as their aliases for
Garth rands one of the founding members
of the Legion of super-heroes by the way
while filming this fan scene Ezra Miller
had to stuff his face with burgers which
I'm guessing would have tied in with
Barry complaining about how hungry he
was later in the Batcave originally we
were going to get the introduction of
iris West to the DC movie universe
however it looks like we won't be seeing
her now until the flashpoint movie
actress Kiersey Clemons was cast and
confirmed she filmed scenes with Zack
Snyder
however she wasn't involved in the
reshoot so it looks like she was a
casualty of the edits the elevator scene
of the team entering the Batcave in
their superhero costumes was changed to
them dressed in just their regular
clothes and the Batcave scenes were also
scaled back reports from the Batcave set
in August last year talk about numerous
scenes of the Justice League joking
around with Alfred which we never got to
see in the movie in one of those scenes
after seeing the number of metahumans
who've suddenly descended on the Batcave
Alfred sarcastically remarks to Bruce
Wayne that if you'd warned me I would
have baked a cake and I'll break open
the party hats and the pinata and also
I'll make some tea don't know where I'll
find the cup
Alfred did still get some nice lines in
Justice League though like his sardonic
Easter egg Laden remark about exploding
windup penguins but there's also some
trailer scenes with him that were
chopped from the final film how do you
know you do strong and there's one scene
in particular that hints there might
have been a different return for
Superman
he said you've come now let's hope
you're not too late the way the film
played out suggests this might have been
Superman visiting the Batcave after he
disappeared to his family's farmhouse
with Lois alternatively in this cutscene
maybe Lois Lane who Alfred is talking to
after all Batman has asked him to bring
in the big gun to help them deal with
the volatile resurrected Superman Clark
and Lois also had their scene in
Smallville cut down and you can see the
missing part in the trailers I'll take
that as a yes what the ring we do see
Lois touch her ring as she talks to
Clark in the movie but this dialogue
about the ring was Curt Superman moment
that we didn't get to see in the film
was Superman in his black suit now the
black suit appears on a number of comics
including the death of Superman's
storyline in which he was killed by
doomsday and many comic book fans were
hoping for the suit to make an
appearance in Justice League especially
after Henry Cavill posted a photo of a
section from a dark looking Superman
suit on Instagram of course it's
possible that cavil was just having a
bit of fun with fans like Hugh Jackman
did when he posted a picture of a yellow
suited Wolverine toy before Logan was
released by the way the movie does still
give a little nod to Superman's black
suit from the comics by the dark
seemingly black trousers that Superman
was after he's resurrected as well as in
the color of the Superman banners on
buildings after his death and despite
having a shortish screen time in Justice
League Henry Cavill was still involved
in the reshoots which meant the
moustache he had for his role in Mission
Impossible had to be digitally removed
in post-production when the woman's
opening scene in London where she saves
a group of hostages from a terrorist
group looks like it could have played
out quite differently
the trailers seemed to reveal the bomb
going off inside the building suggesting
that in this version she might not have
saved all the hostages which makes me
wonder if this was reshot to have a
happier outcome at the beginning of the
film rather than something darker
because in the actual movie Danna throws
the bomb through the roof saving
everyone
I noticed a major visual change in the
final act when the Justice League go to
Russia to take down Steppenwolf in the
first trailer the scenes for this part
of the film all have a bluish color
whereas in later trailers has changed
quite drastically to read the decision
to have red skies might be a reference
to the red skies from the crisis on
Infinite Earths comic book storyline or
perhaps a nod to the fiery hellish
landscape of the planet apocalypse which
Steppenwolf hails from however I think
the red filter on the scenes might have
contributed to the CGI looking less
realistic in the final battle compared
to the original look speaking of
Steppenwolf the movies Big Bad has some
menacing dialogue deleted from the
trailers where he references the fact
there's nobody protecting the earth and
there is still a few more deleted scenes
one is a shot of the team walking into
STAR Labs another is a cool shot of
Wonder Woman facing off against
Steppenwolf with Aquaman and Cyborg
behind her
shall we in the final movie we only see
her alone in this pose
now our any deleted scenes you wish had
been included in the movie and are you
happier with the shorter runtime and
lighter tone or would you prefer
something darker be sure to let me know
in the comments below and don't forget
to also subscribe for your chance to win
one of these to Justice League the art
of the film books the winners of my Thor
Ragnarok giveaway are on the screen
right now and here's the winner of my
stranger things giveaway as well if
that's you be sure to send me a message
with your details so I can get your
prize is out to you also while you're
here check out some more of my Justice
League and movie deleted scenes videos
by tapping the screen here thanks for
watching and see you next time you
became movie lovers